I'm here today with in a new place
trying out something new.
I'm talking to Charlie Kirk and Charlie
is a native of Chicago and he's been
working,
building an organization in the US to
promote free speech on campuses for,
for how long now?
It's been six years now.
Okay.
Well I'm gonna let you take it away and
tell people exactly what you've been up
to.
Sure.
So I,
uh,
started this organization called turning
point USA when I was 18 years old.
Uh,
took a very unusual path to it.
I decided to start this movement instead
of going to college.
I saw something brewing in the states
that I felt more instinctual than
anything else,
that there was a countercultural kind of
revolution that needed to happen on our
college and high school campuses.
And I saw it through social media and I
saw it from my local high school
community that my generation was being
so inundated with cultural Marxism and
also economic Marxism,
but even worse,
it was a cultural side of it and that my
generation was yearning for a different
perspective and political viewpoint or
at least ideological diversity.
And the capacity to have your viewpoints
challenged.
So it started as kind of a whim.
Um,
has ended up to be a quite large success
when I started this organization,
I had no idea what I was doing.
I had no political connections and no
money.
So,
um,
that,
uh,
that was a good start.
So what,
so you,
you started thinking about this when you
were in high school.
That's great.
Okay.
So what happened in high school and how
did you come to these conclusions and
what motivated you?
Always loved history,
economics,
and of the more conservative persuasion.
My lifelong ambition.
I wanted to go to the United States
Military Academy at West Point,
which is a very difficult school to get
into in the states.
So I got my congressional nomination,
which is the first of a two step
process.
And then I ended up being waitlisted and
denied,
uh,
my senior year of high school,
which totally shattered me,
but ended up being the best thing that
ever happened to me,
uh,
because it really made me reflect on who
I was and what I wanted to do.
And what I realized is my motivation to
go to the military academy was that I
was a patriot and I love my country and
I wanted to serve in some capacity,
but I felt like the west was under
attack and I still feel that to this
day.
So.
And so why do you think you develop
the sense of patriotism and in say
junior high and high school when,
when that is increasingly lacking?
I would say not only locking,
but seriously criticized.
What made you different?
It's difficult to say.
I definitely love my country based on my
upbringing,
but my,
my,
my parents are generally center,
right people.
And we're always taught,
you know,
patriotic values from a young age.
Read the constitution,
you know,
around the dinner table,
things like that.
But I'm disagreeable by nature.
And so when my parents,
when my teachers would go out of their
way to make anti American or anti
patriotic statements and only made me
reaffirm my own beliefs and dig in
deeper and want to challenge that even
more,
which I then sought out the great
thinkers of the American founding,
the federalist papers,
the US Constitution,
and down that rabbit hole I went to the
great thinkers that created Western
civilization both intentionally and
unintentionally,
whether it be aristotle and all the
great enlightened,
you know,
thousands of years of writings that the
founding fathers drew inspiration from.
And did you do that on your own?
That's correct.
It was autodidactic.
So it was self taught in middle school
as well,
but it was,
it was driven by this inspiration of I
want it to be able to effectively
articulate my beliefs and values and
ideas to a core of teachers that felt as
if they had to indoctrinate me to hate
America,
hate free enterprise and hate free
speech.
So I grew up in a rather generally
liberal area.
The northwest suburbs of Chicago and the
teacher community for the most part,
they were not trying to allow a free
flow of ideas.
They were trying to impose a specific
doctrine upon their students and being a
disagreeable contrarian by nature,
I would always debate them and I would
find satisfaction and proving them wrong
as you know,
as wrong or right is that might be.
That's just who I was.
So we always have been.
And then by doing so I sought out these
books.
I sat out these ideas and I found Milton
Friedman and I found individuals that,
that articulated what I knew to be true
and I only went down that path even
further.
So what did that do for your social
life?
Just out of curiosity,
how were your,
how were your peers reacting to this?
Um,
so it's quite interesting you,
you mentioned that throughout high
school I was heavily involved in
football and basketball and it
generally,
well liked individual,
um,
ever since my graduation of high school
in my entrance into political and social
activism,
the hostility towards my from my high
school community towards me has been
extreme.
And I'm not trying to play a victim.
I'm fine with it.
I really.
Those people were never my friends.
They just pretended to be them to be,
to be as such.
But it's amazing to me that you just
have a different viewpoint on how the
world should work.
That people on the left will immediately
ostracize you and categorize you
differently.
And I always say,
you know,
I'm a conservative.
I don't look at people that are on the
left any differently than I did.
I looked at who they are as a character
and as a person.
And the politics are just layered on top
of that.
The left is completely different,
is if you disagree with them.
That's who you become.
And I think that's one of the most
cancerous and divisive aspects of modern
political culture today is that,
um,
especially my generation,
if you dare not be a leftist or dare not
be a liberal,
then you're somehow less human or you're
somehow less acceptable to them or
you're immediately intolerant or racist
or bigoted or homophobic.
Which of course is untrue.
But it's almost as if they view you as a
subspecies of them,
which I'm experiencing every day and
some of the categorizations thrown
towards you.
It seems that in popular culture that
remains consistent.
So,
so.
Okay.
So tell me about your organization.
Tell me its scope now and in what should
be doing and then we can talk about how
you built it.
Of course.
So we're on 1300 college in high school
campuses across the states.
We have 115 people on full time staff
and last year we raised 10 and a half
million dollars a with 25,000
active donors and some big ones,
some small ones with some of the
largest,
most successful American business people
that had been investing in us.
And I just started it from nothing,
just I traveled 340 days a year,
um,
and meeting with investors and business
people and entrepreneurs that are
worried that America is in grave decline
and I'm able to present them with a
strategy and a plan and a vision that
can help turn that around.
No Pun intended,
a organization's called turning point
USA.
And so we host the nations largest
annual gathering of young conservatives
will have 5,000
students there this upcoming December,
of which you're the most requested
speaker off the charts I might add.
Um,
and the scope of the organization is
dramatic and immense.
Will we have a young women's leadership
summit in June.
We'll have 1200 young ladies from across
from all 50 states attend,
that's in June in Dallas,
Texas.
Um,
and so we will host over 100 events a
year off campus with over 250 student
activists and leaders that we train
towards what I like to call more
principle based activism things that,
you know,
created the West free speech dialogue,
a free enterprise private property
rights,
natural rights,
really diving into the deep ideas,
not this sort of social justice left
this activism that is taught from our
lecture halls.
Um,
so the scope of the organization has
really grown dramatically.
We're on a $15,000,000
budget this year.
Um,
and it's,
it's been quite an experience and a
blessing to say the least right place,
right time with a great group of people.
And how many,
how many campuses now a 1300 college and
high school campuses represented
throughout the states.
And so what's happening at the high
school level,
chapter development,
it's quite interesting.
We have seen an explosion of high school
interest and chapter development over
the last couple of years,
especially because the activism that is
so prevalent in our colleges has now
stepped down into our high schools and
so students that are finding my videos
are finding Dave and or Ben Shapiro,
Dennis Prager,
your content there are now 14,
15 and 16 and they seek out that content
because they have to,
if they want to be able to defend their
beliefs because it used to be that
college used to be the only place that
these ideas were really.
I'm not the only place I should say,
but the,
the,
the main focus of the left was colleges
no more.
I mean they are teaching the,
the beginning stages of postmodernism as
early as freshman year in high school
where there is no such thing.
Yeah.
Stereo is early as grade one.
That's correct.
Yeah,
that's right.
So in Ontario,
the elementary teachers association,
that's not quite the right name,
maybe,
so Ontario Teachers' federation and I
can't remember at the moment,
but they've put in a,
they put together a social justice
curriculum from grade one to grade
eight,
which even bends the study of literature
itself in a social justice direction.
So there so shameless that they're
willing to bend art to the purposes
political propaganda.
It's stunning.
It is.
It's quite remarkable.
So what do you expect from the high
school chapters?
What do you,
what is it that they're doing that you
think is good and useful?
So it's,
it's a different strategy and it's
different implementation that are staff.
Staff goes about when they deal with
high school students.
The number one thing with high school
students,
the high school chapters that we deal
with is trying to make it culturally
acceptable to believe these conservative
ideas.
So even if they meet weekly and bring in
a guest speaker of a local,
you know,
political nature or they watch video,
it's much more of a comradery building
activity in high school than in college.
And I say that because in the mindset of
being in high school is quite different
in college,
you're,
you're entering into kind of that rugged
independence.
I want to rebel or conform to my parents
ideology in high school,
you still are still very much anchored
to your local and cultural institutions,
your high school football team or
basketball team.
And so,
but we've here.
That's exactly right.
Whereas College,
by the time the dynamic of the geography
of college you break,
you try to break out of that.
Um,
but we,
we,
we try to hold them the high school
chapters to a specific standard of at
least meeting weekly,
trying to go to some of our big national
events,
hosting guest speakers,
debates and lectures.
So a great example is in the states,
there was that horrific shooting down in
Parkland high school.
I'm going to go down and I'm actually
going down to MSD,
um,
uh,
the,
the school where the shooting took
place.
I'm going to give a speech on the second
amendment,
natural rights.
They're not allowing me on campus,
but I'm doing it right across the
street.
So that's one of the groups,
we have a Tuesday coming up this
Tuesday.
They say it's highly controversial,
which I don't consider it to be.
Um,
the second amendment is,
some would say a controversial thing.
People that aren't in the states by the
first amendment is controverted.
That's exactly,
that's what I was going to say is that
the idea of natural rights doesn't,
shouldn't offend anyone,
but unfortunately it does.
So that's one example of an event that I
have on a high school kind of arena that
I'm doing coming on.
Okay.
And then at the university level you
have,
you said 1,513,
so 1300 is the number of high school and
college combined.
So that's divided about 900 college,
400 high school.
Do you have any estimate for total
membership?
It's difficult to say.
So to give you an idea,
we had 3000 students attend our annual
meeting last year and we had over 14,000
applications.
Um,
and so membership as well beyond that.
but it's definitely the tens of
thousands are total data list is in the
hundreds of thousands.
We have over million facebook followers,
either half a million followers on
twitter memberships.
A very difficult thing to pinpoint.
We don't want to define.
That's correct.
We don't want to be like the arp where
you have 7 million people on your
mailing list and you pretend they're all
members,
but I were very much more into the
quality of leadership than the quantity
of leaders,
so that's the one thing.
I'd rather have 100 dedicated,
principled,
a movement driven student leaders than a
thousand that are just kind of
lackluster and are there for the free
pizza or pop [inaudible] and what are
you hoping for from the university
chapters,
so that's much more disruptive.
We want to challenge the status quo,
head on and do everything we possibly
can to try to change the trajectory of
our organ of our generation.
And so our organization offers that in a
lot of different ways,
whether it be offering guest speakers on
campus such as myself.
So this last week I spoke at the
University of California Berkeley and
University of California,
Los Angeles,
a UC Berkeley and Ucla.
One day after the other,
we had a packed house,
a every seat filled.
We had a lot of protestors,
a lot of opposition,
hundreds of thousands of people watch
the live stream.
That live stream will hit a million
people on.
I'm kind of going a retroactive views
happening right now throughout this next
week.
But you said you were there with Ruben
and that's great.
I was there with Dave Rubin and Candice
Owens.
Candice Owens works for us.
She's our communications director.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
so candice is a superstar.
In fact,
she just got a nice shout out from Kanye
West saying,
I love the way candace owens thinks,
which honestly is a.
it's hard to even put into words the
significance of a rap.
Artists like him singling out a
conservative minded pundant like
candice.
I think there's a seismic shift
happening in American,
the black community that is going to be
a generational ideological civil war in
the words of Canada.
So and so.
We went to UC Berkeley and Ucla,
and what's interesting about Candice
Owens is she uses identity politics
against the left and so truth is truth
should be colorblind and any individuals
should be able to say what they want to
say despite their skin color,
their gender unfortunately is not the
case on a college campus.
So I'll say something that might trigger
the audience,
but candace will say that and they're
perfectly okay with that and that
shouldn't be the case,
but that just shows how it must be
harder for her on the contrary side to
be conservative and block without a
doubt.
And the,
the,
the societal punishment she receives for
that is horrific.
Like what,
what's happening?
What are the things that they see?
The words they call her.
I wouldn't even repeat on camera,
but you know,
the nice ones are uncle Tom Coon,
things of that nature.
Um,
she has a very,
just the harsh backlash for what she
believes in,
what she feels because how dare she
stray away from the ideological monopoly
that the left has on the black
community.
And for those that people that don't
know,
that might be watching internationally,
the Democrat Party receives 90,
sixth and 97 percent of all black voters
in America,
despite the Democrat policies having
the,
the worst impact on the black community.
And so candice is trying to wake up that
community and so we're happy to have her
as our communications director and help
enhance her,
her,
um,
her vision to try to a least get people
to think differently.
I'm going to talk to Warren Farrell
later today.
And he just wrote a book called the boy
crisis.
And in there he talks a fair bit about
the pernicious effects of
fatherlessness.
And that's something that I'm very
interested in,
in,
in Ontario,
we have as part of standard political
policy that all families are equal,
you know.
And the idea there is that respect
should be given to familial units
regardless of their structure.
And you know,
there's something to be said for that
because people have to struggle through
life the best they can,
whether they're single parents are or
regardless of how they put their family
together.
But the empirical data on the
catastrophe of fatherlessness is
extraordinarily solid in deep and it
seems to be something in principle
that's a particular place for the black
community that's currently.
I guess I'm wondering too,
like with the conservative approach to
that are,
are,
have you guys focused on the problems of
fatherlessness and,
and what,
what's your take on that?
Oh,
and without a,
without a doubt,
if I had to pinpoint one,
um,
societal trend that has harmed the black
community most who'd be the rise of
single motherhood in the US.
So to give a number just to,
to so people understand the single
motherhood rate in the 19 sixties,
about 18 percent in the black community
now 77 percent,
77 percent of us blacks will grow up
never knowing their father if there is
no,
there's no rational argument that,
that is healthy for a society.
And the reason for that,
there's an article in the Atlantic
monthly just two weeks ago showing that
which is,
which is more notable,
right?
Because it's not like the Atlantic is a
right leaning magazine anything,
but yeah.
Yeah.
And you know,
I mean,
they can be
and handed when they're at their best
and they reviewed the new evidence that
was presented in this research paper,
which I also read showing that if you
look at those few locales where poor
black people and poor white people do
approximately as well,
if you track them over as a reasonable
amount of time,
um,
the,
the thing that characterizes the high
functioning poor poorer places is the
presence of fathers.
That's
exactly right.
They said that not only the researchers
claim that not only was that good in the
immediate family,
so they have your father around,
but in neighborhoods where having
fathers around is the norm.
Every boy in particular does better in
the neighborhood since right?
And every single crime goes down,
the likelihood of not going to prison
obviously goes down.
But the interesting questions we have to
ask why?
So we as conservatives always try to
ask,
what is the reason this is happening at?
Whereas the left,
I don't always think they go through
that or they ignore it willingly.
The reason is because the great society
that was passed by Lyndon Baines Johnson
in the 19 sixties where the US
government literally subsidized single
motherhood where if you got married,
you lost your government check and it
still exists to this day in the states
where the idea and the intention was,
well,
let's try to help single mothers.
Okay,
that's fine.
I don't think anyone doesn't.
Doesn't want to help single mothers.
The problem is as soon as you get
married,
you lose that checked because it was a
program designed for single motherhood
and so you incentivize bad behavior.
You get more of it,
and that's exactly what you've seen in
the states.
You couple that with a disastrous public
education system run by public sector
teacher unions that have no
accountability protected by tenure,
and I'm really embrace mediocrity.
It's highest form with I'm failing urban
cities with Democrat mayors that have no
grasp of free enterprise or how to
properly run any sort of organization,
let alone a massive municipality or
city.
That's why you have the black community
failing so much.
The final point I'll say is this,
in the states,
the two poorest communities by race,
if you will,
um,
are the two communities that receive the
most government assistance per capita,
the native American community and the
African American community.
And so we can draw a direct correlation
in distinction between the rise of the
welfare state in America and actually
the decline of the black community,
native American community and,
but the solution to that is black
fathers.
And so we always say black fathers
matter whether it seems
to be an employment issue too.
And I mean that's a complicated problem
because you know that the employment
market for people who are less skilled
has,
has been,
I would say,
in decline,
especially on the male end of the
distribution.
And one of the stats that feral sites is
that three quarters of women will not
consider seriously dating and unemployed
man.
Whereas one third of men would have a
problem dating an unemployed woman.
So there's obviously a gender bias
there.
And I think there's a reason for that.
I think that it's grounded and it's
grounded in both rationality and
evolutionary biology.
The evolutionary biology element is that
women across cultures tend to mate
across and up hierarchies,
let's say.
That's right,
and the reason for that I think is that
there are logically,
and this is where the logic comes in as
well as the biology.
They're looking for a partner that can
be of substantial economic utility,
practical utility when they put
themselves in the vulnerable position of
having a child.
So then you also have this additional
problem is if the employment situation
tanks in any serious way than men become
less desirable as partners and your
claim.
I guess in part is that by filling that
void,
the government actually contributes to
the problem rather than than addressing
it.
It's exactly.
That's tied in I suppose too,
with the high rates of incarceration for
black people in the united
given negative feedback loop where you
get more of that bad behavior.
So the black fathers go to prison,
so they're not there to raise the kids.
The kids go to gangs,
so they'll end up either dead in prison,
hopeless or completely directionless.
The black single mothers who want to
continue to do what's right for the
community,
they have a,
they're left with very few choices,
have more kids,
so it's a negative feedback loop,
so you have,
you have bad behavior,
reinforcing bad behavior,
subsidized by the government.
Then you have the complete destruction
of what used to be a somewhat civilized
portion of American life,
which if you look at the worst areas in
America,
it's the inner cities,
predominantly with the African American
community and so that the final,
the interesting point is how on earth is
it that black people today,
their grandfathers lived a better life
than their fathers was?
America is America is more racist today
than it was in the 19 sixties.
Absolutely not.
America's become significantly less
racist,
but if you look to the American left or
the social justice warriors of the
academic and the Neo Marxist,
they pinpoint racism as the significant
driving force to why black people are
doing poorly in America.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's a problem too that I've talked
about with regards to gender inequality
in pay,
which you've been wonderful.
Yeah.
Well,
um,
there's a lot of different reasons for
different.
If you analyze differences in important
attributes by group,
whatever your group measure is,
you're going to find that there's a
dozen contributors,
you know,
just to pick a multivariate analysis to
use your quote.
Yeah.
Well,
and the thing is,
is that you can,
you can attribute a certain amount of
the difference in success between groups
to,
let's call it racial attitudes or
ethnocentrism on the part of the
dominant group.
It's complicated because in the U,
s Asians do rebel spectacularly well.
Jews do well.
Nigerians do pretty damn well.
Black immigrants do quite well.
That's correct.
So,
so it's much more complex than a simple
racial analysis would indicate.
And the problem I guess in part with the
group fostered analysis is that people
make the claim that a single factor,
prejudice essentially is the cause of
all the problems.
And then that has the additionally
pernicious effect of blanketing everyone
who isn't in the oppressed group that's
being spoken for at the moment as
oppressors.
And also,
and this is an even more pernicious
element,
and I,
I really believe that this is part of
the fundamental motivation of the
pathological left,
is that there's a war on the idea of
competence itself,
you know,
because if you take someone who's worked
hard and,
and being productive and being useful
and admirable in all the ways that you
might hope someone was,
and then you tell them that the only
reason that they've been successful is
because of their skin color,
let's say,
and this systemic racism next
characterized as the society than what
you do is undermine the entire idea that
competence itself might be the basis of
a hierarchy and that way.
And I really think that,
that,
that desire to undermine the idea that
hierarchies can be based on competence
is associated with the deep Marxism
that's associated with the radical left.
And I can't think of an idea that's more
pernicious than that.
That's right.
And I have to tell you,
Jordan,
I've been doing this for a long time,
but I've been doing it for at least an
equivalent,
you know,
six years of college activism and
organizing.
And your video on postmodernism and neo
Marxism,
I remember exactly where I was.
I was driving to the University of
Michigan just a couple months ago and I,
I literally my car,
I said I finally get it.
I finally understand what is motivating
these people,
the philosophy behind it,
and it was an hour and a half video
where you really dissected postmodernism
and it's exactly,
it's exactly what you just said.
They,
they want the death of the individual,
the death of logos,
that any sort of success can be
attributed to some sort of red
prejudice.
That's exactly right.
The equation of success with our
literally purchased.
I can't explain to you how significant
that was.
I also think that's tied in with what
you might describe as the,
let's say,
the decline of boys,
assuming that that sort of thing is,
is reasonable.
Um,
if you tell boys that the pay,
first of all that society is a
patriarchy,
which it isn't.
If you tell them that and then you say,
well,
not only is it a patriarchy to corrupt
patriarchy,
it's a corrupt,
destructive,
racist,
prejudice,
patriarchy,
and that anyone who succeeds and it is
therefore a corrupt prejudice and racist
because that's how you would succeed in
a hierarchy like that.
Then what you do is you associate in the
minds of people who might participate in
the project,
the idea that any success whatsoever is
actually a moral flaw.
And I've seen that happen to lots of
people,
had a friend in particular who bought
that line and he had other problems as
well,
but he really believed that active
engagement with the world,
any pursuit of success on his part for
him and for his family and for his
community,
but let's say for him to begin with was
merely,
um,
was merely engagement in the process by
which the entire world is being
destroyed and brought to its knees.
He really believed that and it really.
Many things destroyed him.
But that was certainly one of the things
that destroyed him.
And you know,
there's no differentiation in history is
obviously a bloody nightmare.
And there's no way around that,
but it's necessary to differentiate
between activity that is good and
activity that is evil,
and to state that all activity that
supports the patriarch in God,
I can't stand it that we even have to
use that language,
but it's it,
it is more widespread and universities
than people realize you understand it.
But for most parents,
there is a concerted effort to de
legitimize and I wouldn't say destroy
the idea of the white Christian male in
North American school,
especially the male aspect of it.
We're taught from the beginning stages
that there is a patriarchy.
It's rigged against women.
When in reality,
the numbers show men are far more likely
to commit suicide.
Men are not living as long as women.
Men are much more likely to go to
prison,
much more likely to declare bankruptcy,
much more likely to be killed at work.
That's exactly right.
Women are graduating in college in
record numbers.
Women 14 or 15 years have a dominated in
the math,
got more master's degrees and more phds
than men.
Um,
and there's another interesting stat to
that
you never hear discussed by feminists
and it actually drives me.
It's one of the many things that drives
me to distraction,
let's say,
is that man,
let's,
except for a moment that all that on
average men make more money than women.
Although the reasons for that,
as we've already discussed,
are extraordinarily complicated.
Women spend.
The last time I looked something
approximating 75 to 80 percent of the
consumer dollar.
It's exact and you can make a real.
At least you can pose it as a question.
It's like,
well,
who has the economic upper hand?
Is it the person who makes the money or
is it the person who spends the money?
And I think that's a real question
because most of the men that I know that
are worth their salt,
it's like the competitive guys.
Often they're out for money because
that's the way they keep score.
The competition.
You really see that in places like law
firms where it's correct.
Everyone's heavily competitive and
they're always,
they always have an eye on the bonus
because they're trying to climb up the
hierarchy and in large part from a
biological perspective that's actually
to make them attractive to women.
So,
but if,
if the,
if men are generally men or are
motivated to earn heavily,
to be attractive in part,
which is certainly part of it,
and to take their place in the male
hierarchy and,
and to succeed there,
then it also means that a huge part of
their motivation is to distribute the
money and you know,
and to distribute it to who?
Well,
at least in principle to their wife and
their kids.
And I mean if you,
if you're a man of any utility and you
meet another man who's fundamentally
oriented,
it is selfish direction.
Who's hoarding his money without any
concern for how it might be utilized?
Who's spending it all on,
let's call them juvenile adolescent
impulsive pleasures.
Refusing to share.
It's not like that.
Someone that you admire in someone you
have contempt for right away.
Right?
And so if you ever meet someone who's
like the stereotype of the successful
patriarchal male,
then he's not somebody that fills you
with admiration.
You're looking for someone who.
And the people I know that have been
successful financially that I've admired
and there's been many of them have done
amazing things.
They've produced technologies that are
world changing often,
you know,
and but they're hyper concerned with
what it is that they're going to do with
their money and how it should be well
spent and where it would do the most
good.
And like,
I don't want to whitewash,
I don't want to whitewash our society,
but the idea that people are
fundamentally motivated by the sorts of
selfish motivations that only accrue
benefit to them and no one else is.
It's a preposterous claim.
And I,
I just don't see any evidence whatsoever
that that's the case.
I agree.
And one of the other components of it
that is taught in our schools,
which one of the top things I have to
dispel is the idea that just because
someone gets rich,
someone got poor,
the zero sum game.
And so there's an idea that has
penetrated the minds of youth in America
that I can't believe.
It's like,
oh,
this guy has a million bucks.
He must have stole it from someone else.
Wrong.
You,
you had to create value in order to get
that money,
in fact,
or at least some people do that,
like you could say and should say that,
you know,
in every hierarchical enterprise of any
scale,
there's going to be a fractional
criminal element without maybe you could
say,
well,
it's five percent of the sum total of
the activity.
And the problem with the criminal part
of it is that it tends not to be very
self sustaining,
you know?
So you hear,
well there's lots of psychopaths in
business.
It's like,
yeah,
but they can eat,
they get pushed out,
they do.
And they otherwise they have to move
from place to place because their
reputations followed them around.
And your reputation is actually quite
fragile.
And so you could say,
well,
amongst the pool of people who are
wealthy,
there's a element that have obtained
that wealth through,
um,
through means that aren't admirable.
Sure.
For reasons that aren't socially
beneficial,
but to then say then say,
because of that existence of that small
fraction of people,
which is actually ineradicable right,
you,
you can't have a certain amount of
freedom without a certain amount of
criminality.
I think the American America is a really
good example of that.
To say that that means that everyone
who's been successful is a thief.
It's like you have to be very careful
when you make a claim like chef because
it also means that if you're successful,
then you're a thief and that's a hell of
a value structure to adopt and I would
make the argument that the mark,
the free market system forces you to be
a better person.
It forces you to tell the truth and
create a better product and treat your
customers well and to be responsive when
something goes wrong or to lower your
price or to improve the mechanism of
which you are interacting with.
The customers aren't demanding that they
don't have choice,
you know,
and that's another.
That's another example of a different
kind of cognitive problem,
let's say,
is that people are taught,
people aren't taught that.
Comparing what we have to.
They're hypothetical politically,
politically,
ideologically motivated.
Utopia is actually a bad idea,
you know,
because it's,
it just isn't difficult to take a look
at a system like our system and say,
well,
look at all the problems that has
compared to a hypothetical system that
doesn't have any problems at all.
It's like,
well,
yeah man,
there's problems.
There's,
you know,
we've,
we've taken like 99 percent of the fish
out of the ocean and,
and you know,
the degree to which our current level of
economic activity is truly sustainable
without alteration is at least
debatable.
Even though I don't think it's nearly as
terrible as people make out,
make it out to be.
But I don't think it's disputable that
our current socioeconomic structures are
the most productive and the most free
structures that have ever been produced
by people anywhere in the world.
And one of the things you can say about
capitalism and free enterprise and and
the western stress on individuality is
that even though it does produce
inequality,
a all systems produce inequality and and
without any real distinction between the
right and the left,
by the way,
because I'm so new book called the Great
Leveler by Walter Shadelle,
who I'm going to be talking to later
this month.
He did an analysis,
empirical analysis trying to figure out
if you,
if you grouped governments by right wing
philosophy say or by left wing
philosophy and then you calculated
inequality coefficient.
Would that left wing organizations be
characterized by reduced inequality?
And the answer was no.
There's no evidence that they are.
And what that points to,
and this is something very fundamental,
it's far more fundamental than that
political,
is that inequality is the rule in
cooperative slash competitive
organizations.
You can't pause it,
a value without producing a hierarchy,
right?
Because you pause it,
devalues,
say this is worth doing.
And everyone says,
yeah,
this is worth doing.
Well.
Then what happens automatically is that
it turns out that some people are better
at doing it than other people.
No matter what it is,
I'm going to get better and better at
it.
Like the cradle plus you're talking
about too,
and then they start getting better at
it.
So the problem is is that without you
with if you're going to pause it,
value which you have to do,
if you're going to act and immediately
you create a hierarchy and you also
build into the value claim,
the claim that a is better than b.
You also build into that the idea that
if a is better than B,
than people who are doing better at a
should be differentially rewarded
compared to people who who aren't.
There's no way around that if you're
going to play the game and so you're
stuck with an equality,
but there isn't any evidence that that
social engineering policies are really
very good at dispensing with inequality,
which is a fundamental political problem
and no one really knows what to do about
it.
But criticizing the entire society.
I mean,
the thing about the west and this is
increasingly true all over the world,
is that it's generating our approach
generates a tremendous amount of wealth
for.
I mean it even happened in China,
you know,
despite their exceptionally totalitarian
leanings,
and so what happens with the lefties is
that they say,
well,
inequality as a consequence of the west
and the consequence of capitalism,
which is palpably false claim and say,
well,
because it produces inequality,
then it's a corrupt system.
It's like,
no,
every system produces inequality,
but hardly any also produce wealth.
That's correct.
And Mobility and and reward for
creativity,
entrepreneurial activity and risk
taking.
That's,
that's something that the free market
system is quite unique at and whereas a
more neo Marxist view,
how do you get rich and a socialist?
You run for political office.
That's true.
Exploitation is you run on the best
intentions of the public while
implementing what you believe to be the
best socially engineered construct.
Look at Venezuela.
I mean the leaders are doing just fine.
Meanwhile,
people are dying on the streets,
you know,
13,000
percent inflation,
so on and so forth.
So I have a question for you and I've
watched hundreds of hours of your
content on the Internet and you've
opened up my mind in ways I cannot
describe.
You've made me a better speaker.
You've made me a better lecture,
a better person,
more organized,
more I can draw a direct corollary to
our organization's budget and everything
from when I first interacted with your
content because I'd never heard anyone
describe the reality of life.
Life is suffering.
What are you going to do about it?
Just so bluntly and so directly,
but with struggle up the.
Damn.
That's,
that's exactly right.
With a roadmap to deal with that
because.
And I'll tell you something cool and
then I'll get the other question.
No,
no,
no problem.
We have this program and it might be
something in the future off your
pronunciation.
Yeah.
I've used it with people that have done
that with drug problems.
Huh?
Well,
we have a fairly new study that came out
last year.
I'm from Mohawk College.
She's a junior college,
um,
with the vocational element.
And the kids came in during the summer
in their orientation and spent an hour
writing out their life plan,
right?
How,
how they,
what they would like to have in their
life across six standard dimensions,
intimate relationship,
family education,
care of their own mental and physical
health strategies for dealing with
temptation like drug and alcohol use,
um,
useful application of their time outside
of,
outside of their obligations.
So the question is,
it's like it's,
it's,
it's sort of predicated on a new
testament principle,
I would say in part,
which is know if you could have what you
wanted by asking what,
what would you ask asking you shall
receive knock and you will answer it.
It's in Matthew.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's in Matthew and,
and the idea there,
I think from a psychological perspective
is that while you're not going to get
what you want,
unless you know what it is and you're
not going to hit target lists,
you aim for it course and you can't even
organize your perceptions in
relationship to the world unless you
have a goal.
Okay?
So you write down what you think you
might want and need in order to stand
your life and then you write for awhile
about how,
what your life could be like in three to
five years if you put your,
if you,
what your vision would be for your life,
three to five years.
And then you read a counter vision which
is an analysis of where you might be in
three to five years if you let all your
bad habits take the upper hand and then
you write a plan.
Okay.
And it takes a long time to do a really
good job of that.
But it turns out that you can do a bad
job of it in about an hour.
And so we had kids at Mohawk do it for
an hour when they came in for their
summer orientation and it knocked the
dropout rate for young men down 50
percent.
And so I thought it just just blew me
away because it's sad,
you know,
I thought,
just look at that.
If you get young guys to sit down and
think for an hour about what they would
like their life to be,
it decreases the probability that
they'll drop out of college by 50
percent.
It's a kind of hell man kind of
correlation.
It's just stunning.
Well,
it's.
We have three studies demonstrating that
was the biggest effect.
I've seen it.
I,
I'm dealing currently with one of my
best high school buddies that was an
opioid since a huge problem in America
and I'm guessing here in Canada it is as
well.
Not as well versed in it.
And I sat him down and I did the future
authoring program and it changed his
life and you know,
and I made him watch all your videos and
became hooked on it and it saved no
opiates.
Yeah,
you saved his life.
I can say that.
And you changed my life.
I wouldn't say you say it because I
wasn't in that same dire condition,
but the number one thing I said to him,
I said,
listen buddy,
and I can use his name to protect his
privacy.
I said,
your whole life,
you've been seeking freedom.
He's like,
yeah,
that's what I've been told.
I said,
things in life that give you meaning
will come from responsibility and
that's.
That's what click.
One of the things that you said that
really clicked with me,
a good thing to know,
man,
we have inundated,
especially young men,
go seek freedom.
Go do you want how you want to do it
when you want to do,
which is fine.
There's nothing inherently wrong to that
when you're young,
but if you really want meaning,
if you want satisfaction,
if you want direction,
it's the stuff that has consequence.
It's family work.
That's exactly right.
Freedom is.
Freedom is not teaching young millnet
intentionally.
That's the other thing I wanted to get
to,
but go ahead.
I think it's intentional.
I think it is too because it's part and
parcel of the idea that the productive
activity of young men,
and this also goes for the masculine
symbolically masculine activity of young
women by the way,
but the productive activity of a young
man is indistinguishable from the
forest.
That gives rise to the,
to the crushing tyranny of the
patriarchy.
It's like,
well,
and that also gives young men at a moral
excuse not to engage in life.
It's like,
well,
you know,
productive activities.
See it all the time.
I've been told I'm a horrible person my
whole life.
W,
w what uses this to me?
I'm going to go play video games in my
basement.
Yeah.
I've been told from all my teachers and
my parents that,
you know,
it's rigged.
You know that I'm a horrible individual
just because I'm a man and it really
diminishes a men that might want to
succeed.
And I see it happen all the time.
Yeah,
well it gives them an excuse to the
useless part of men that don't want to
succeed because it's easy to sit around.
I mean,
it isn't because the longterm
consequences of that are just absolutely
devastating.
Start.
See.
So when we have a discussion about
freedom,
you know,
we might also say,
well,
the freedom is.
I think this is right,
is it's freedom to pick your poison.
It's freedom to pick your
responsibility.
That's good.
We might say,
well,
there's,
there's a set of weights in front of you
that you have to pick up in order to
stand yourself,
because that's the other thing I think
about human beings.
Well,
you know,
we conscientiousness is a trait and it
we don't have an animal model for
conscientiousness.
In fact,
we don't understand conscientiousness at
all from a,
from a,
from a psychological or Darwinian
perspective.
Well that's,
that's more complicated because I'm
conscientious.
Men tend to do better and so they're
going to be more successful,
but.
But we don't have a model for what
conscientiousness is,
but but conscientiousness is at least in
part this the the necessity to carry a
load for yourself and for other people
or to suffer guilt and shame as a
consequence.
And so that's.
That seems built in especially to
conscientious people.
Now,
conscientious people didn't more tend to
be more conservative because that's one
of the predictors of conservatism,
but it could easily be that freedom is
the freedom to choose your yoke,
let's say,
and you and then you choose the weight
that you have to carry so that you can
justify your miserable existence to
yourself so that you can go to bed at
the end of the night and you can think,
look,
I,
I did what I needed to do to set things
right today and I don't have to carry
the existential wait around of my
failure and uselessness.
As a consequence.
The existential psychologist in the 19
fifties who emerged out of the chaos of
world war two were very much.
I'm very much concentrated on the idea
of existential guilt.
You know,
that you owed,
you owed being a ransom for your
existence and the way that you paid that
ransom was to work for the betterment of
being.
I mean,
it's a very ancient idea,
but of course,
but it is the one idea I think that
gives people the self respect,
not self esteem,
the self respect that's necessary to
carry them through terrible times and to
use a story that people are familiar
with.
When I'm asked to what,
what is Jordan Peterson done for your
members?
People,
United States,
he has to stop acting like Peter Pan so
that they can actually be a man and not
a boy.
The Peter Pan Story is a really
interesting one.
A because Peter Pan Pan means
everything,
right?
Technically that's what pan means.
And Peter Pan Wants to be a child
because a child can be anything.
It can be everything.
Right?
So what you have in childhood is that a
plethora of potential and the problem
with growing up is that you have to
sacrifice that,
that pan potential for a defined
actuality,
right?
That's,
that's,
that's to grow up and become something
instead of staying potentially anything.
Now,
the problem with Peter Pan is that he
looks into the world and,
and sees captain hook as his role model.
Right?
And so that's his model for,
for adulthood and hook is terrified of
death.
That's the crocodile is chasing him with
a clock in his stomach and the crocodile
already has a piece of it,
but it's got a taste of him.
And so hook is constantly chased by the
dragon of chaos essentially.
That's already got a taste of him.
And because hook is terrified of his own
mortality and terrified in general,
he's a tyrant.
And so pan looks at Hook and says,
well,
if that's adulthood,
I'd rather stay king of the lost boys.
That's exactly right.
And so yeah,
it's a very powerful story.
Well,
which is why people still tell it 100
years later.
That's correct.
But what I see,
at least from my experience is that the
I,
that idea of staying a boy is idolized
and is made more culturally acceptable
in America than ever has been.
And it's almost as if that you,
you ask a young man that is generally on
the direction towards,
um,
hopelessness and just kind of what you
bring men out of it is they look towards
that MTV vh one lifestyle of being able
to do whatever you want to do,
how you want to do it,
get extraordinarily drunk,
have no responsibility,
be with women all day long.
What happens?
You do that for a couple of years.
You end up a horribly miserable person.
And so.
But here's my question,
is,
yeah,
you don't want to be the oldest guy at
the frat party.
No,
that's correct.
that's pretty dismal.
But it's.
Here's my,
here's my distinction though,
is that in some ways it's the women that
are embracing the masculine archetype
and some ways that are being successful.
I mean,
they're,
they're being extraordinarily
responsible and they're,
they're feeling a lot of these positions
quicker than men can't.
I mean they're.
And they're graduating at higher rates
of college and they're declining.
They're declining motherhood,
or they're at least suspending it
throughout the west,
which is,
you could argue for either ways.
There's reasons for that,
but I guess my question is,
well,
I think that the expression of the
masculine spirit and women isn't
denigrated like women don't get accused
of contributing to the patriarchy even
when they take positions in society that
you would think are fully patriarchal
now and which is a strange thing.
So women who go to law school and then
and then practices corporate lawyers say
aren't subject to the same,
what would you call it?
Claim that their activity is
facilitating that the decline of the
planet.
I guess because they're seen as well.
They're there because of their gender.
I suppose they're seen as as as leaders
of the rebellion against the patriarchal
spirit.
Even though structurally it boils down
to the same thing.
Sure.
So that masculine,
classically masculine,
symbolically masculine,
yearning for hierarchical productivity
and competition is rewarded in women but
not in men and which is also a very
perverse thing because it doesn't make
any sense.
It makes sense through the
postmodernists view,
which is they're just undoing the
oppressor ship of the man and the last
one,
hundred 50 years.
So the ends justify the means.
That's the way they look at it.
Whatever power women can take from men
is a good thing.
That's the way they look at it.
Well,
there's a funny thing about that too,
that like I really need this and 12
rules for life.
I was looking at some of the pew
research data,
and I don't remember the figures
precisely,
but the last 15 years,
the percentage of women who young women
who claim that they would like to be
married in a permanent relationship has
gone up a substantial amount.
I don't remember what it was at 50
percent approximately springs to mind,
but a lot at the same time.
It's declined almost the same degree
among young men and so what's.
What's perverse about this,
this is something I've talked to my
daughter a fair a bit about is that I
mean if you ask young women what they
want,
I don't know if they can answer because
I don't know if they know if they're 19
or 20 because I think their heads are so
muddled by what they've been told that
they don't really know,
but my sense is that women want the
opportunity to develop their career in
whatever direction they see fit and fair
enough,
but they want an intimate relationship
and usually I'm monogamous,
one that's permanent and they want to
have the opportunity to have kids and
what you see happening.
Inevitably,
and I believe this to be the case.
I've watched very carefully as I've,
as I've grown up and go to older because
I've worked with women my whole life is
that women are less,
are less compelled by their career as
they approached their thirties and more
compelled by the desire to have a
permanent relationship and biological
too.
I would argue too.
Well,
I mean I think it's.
It's a biological necessity because
women have to have children relatively
young.
That's correct,
but it's interesting to watch it
phenomenologically and even the women
that I've seen who've had very high
powered careers is that as they move
into their,
especially their early thirties,
they start to realize that the career is
a pretty one dimensional enterprise,
even if it's a good career because even
good careers are still jobs and good
careers.
They're also very hard jobs.
They're like 70 hour a week jobs and
they're full bore commitment jobs and to
figure out how to have a career like
that and to have a life,
to have a family,
to have an intimate relationship,
to have children and then to also be
able to take care of them.
That's a very complex.
It's very complex job to manage and so
what's strange is I think what's strange
is that the very things that the
radicals are undermining,
like the monogamous family,
are actually those things that women
most want,
especially as they approach their
thirties.
And so this is a catastrophe on both
ends of the,
of the gender distribution.
So if there's one thing I would love to
get your opinion and take on is an
ideal,
what these college radicals is the,
at least the professors that people that
should know better of the roots of
Western civilization.
The only description that I could give
to their motivation is some people just
want to see the world burn.
It's almost as if they want chaos for
the sake that they were not able to
contribute meaningfully mindfully.
I would love your take on that from a
social psychologist brother-in-law about
this,
and I've thought about it.
What is their intention?
What is.
Well,
the question is to some degree,
what's the intention of resentment and
failure?
Correct?
Look,
let's say that you.
Let's say that you.
Everything hasn't turned out for you the
way you want it and you're angry about
that and maybe you're angry about the
people who have been successful because
they cast you in a dim light,
and so there's the anger that motivates
the desire for destruction.
That's resentment,
right?
And you never want to underestimate evil
triad,
right?
Greed,
envy and resentment.
Something something like arrogance,
arrogance,
deceit and resentment.
That's,
that's a bad trial that'll take you down
and the thing about the thing,
so there's anger and maybe the anger you
want everything to burn,
but there's also the idea to that,
and this is part of the reason that
inequality actually is a problem for
people on the right and on the left is
that if you put people into a position
where they don't have what they need and
want and they can't see a way to get it,
they have high motivation to flip the
game board over and start again or maybe
to try to play a new game.
And so part of the reason that those on
the right for example,
have to be careful not only to raise
wealth overall,
but also to be careful about inequality
is that as societies become more
unequal,
the motivation for those who feel
dispossessed to flip the entire game
overgrows and grows quite rapidly.
And I'd see that sort of resentment in
the universities.
Although it's to some degree,
it's difficult to say why.
Because of course university professors
aren't unsuccessful by any stretch of
the imagination.
Well compensated and they have very
secure positions,
but that,
but there's still on an anti capitalist
ethos that runs through the
universities.
That's difficult to make a to make a
case for it.
Is it?
Is it an.
I tried to figure out,
is it that I know better than you sort
of thing and you deal with these
professors?
Is it that I'm a smarter individual and
we can create society more equitable?
Yeah.
It's partly that.
It's Hubris,
right?
Yeah.
That's partly the rationalist UK Hubris.
Yeah,
absolutely.
That you know that you can systematize
utopia and that you're smart enough to
do that doctorate.
I can figure this stuff out so well and
that you're systematizing of utopia
isn't going to generate an unexpected
consequences.
Now know social scientists should be
much smarter than that because if you're
a social scientist who has any sense,
what you learned from your research is
that the probability that you can
predict the outcome of your procedure,
which is what you're trying to do as a
scientist,
is very low.
You're running experiment predicated on
a hypothesis.
You'll put the procedure in place that's
supposed to put pros to produce the
hypothesized outcome and likely is not,
it doesn't.
And those are,
that's under simple conditions in the
lab where you can control almost
everything.
And then there's also the case that,
and this has been well known among good
social scientists for a long time,
is that large scale social engineering
projects almost never produced the
results that are in that are intended
and they pr because systems are very
complex and you tweak one thing and you
think you're only tweaking one thing,
but you're tweaking 20 things and a lot
of the things that you tweak
inadvertently kick back and get that
too.
Yeah.
So,
um,
it's,
it's a hard thing to push it because I
get this question a lot from because
this is all I deal with.
I deal with the leftist activists and
the social justice mind and to things
that are so important.
The activists are taking over
governments now and at a rapid rate.
The Democrat Party in America has been
taken over by the social justice neo,
Marxist postmodernist left,
um,
and that it's extraordinarily dangerous
to the west and east,
but I'm always,
I'm always asked by people what
motivates them because it's so damn
obvious.
The ideas that they're trying to advance
don't work.
I mean,
we have a plethora of,
with a century of evidence that central
planning will weaken.
Societies will cause or will cause
civilization.
Civilized chaos,
civilization,
chaos will not create wealth,
will cause debt.
So what still motivates them?
I think part of it is just,
it's,
it's actually complexity.
It's like I've been thinking about this
and it's easy.
It's relatively straightforward to
identify pathology on the right,
I think.
And basically you,
you look at claims of racial superiority
and the right wing identity,
politics types who were making claims of
racial superiority.
Everyone says,
well,
you know,
you're wandering down the Nazi pathway
and that's unacceptable.
And virtually everyone,
you know,
99 percent of people agree that that's a
bad idea.
But on the left,
the problem is,
is that it's clear that some
concatenation of leftist policies when
taken to extreme producer catastrophe,
right?
But it's not just the economic,
it's the cultural too.
Absolutely.
But the problem is it's not that easy to
point to which policies you know.
So if you read the Gulag archipelago,
for example,
social units and his work on prison camp
system,
he does a really good job of detailing
out the relationship between the Utopian
policies of the Lennon nests and the
catastrophes that have occurred.
But it's not simple.
You can't point to one thing and you
say,
oh,
well that's like a racial superiority
charger.
It's because,
well,
we want to foster inclusion of oppressed
group who could be against that,
right?
Right.
And we want to,
we want to level the playing field will
go,
yeah,
well exactly.
And so in isolation,
each of these ideas not only sounds
plausible but sounds positively
beneficial,
but the problem is is that you put a
number of them together and somehow
things tilt in a direction that's
really,
really terrible.
But that isn't it.
This is,
this is the other part of it that I try
to dive into.
I asked,
when I do my speeches on campuses,
I asked a series of five questions and
one of the first question is,
are people good or bad by nature?
The Neo Marxists will get in front of a
mic and I have these videos that have
10,
15 million views where they'll try to
argue me.
That argued to me that people are are
good by nature.
It's just the social construct that
makes them bad.
That's one of the big problems is
definitely,
but you're the expert here.
I mean,
you've been doing this for decades and
you have plethora of research.
My argument is always,
well then why do we have to teach
goodness to our youth?
Why do you have to tell young people to
stop crying?
Why do young people pick their parents
against each other?
There?
Were there ever taught that behavior?
Of course la even aggression,
like evidence that aggression is a.
nate is.
I think it's.
Well,
I don't think it's overwhelming.
It's inclusive.
We evolved from chimpanzees.
They go to war,
right?
I mean,
but,
but that's,
that's one of the key things is how did
the neo Marxist find any sort of,
you know,
any sort of intellectual consistency
with believing that then they teach
young people that,
that this is all just a flawed social
construct,
but we're actually good people by
nature,
not aggressive.
We're not prejudiced in any sense.
It's a compelling story because it's
half the true,
you know,
I mean,
part of the reason that human endeavor
is pathologized is because there's a
tyrannical element to social
organization and so you can say,
well people are basically good and
culture makes them bad and you can tell
a good story using those axioms.
I mean,
you can reverse it and you can say no,
people are basically like uncivilized,
barbaric as individuals and that only
society makes them good to the degree
that they're good.
That's the difference between Hobbes and
Rousseau,
right?
Because Russo would argue for the former
and hobbs for the ladder and you can
make a very strong case for both.
And because the case is compelling,
you don't necessarily hear the other
side of the story.
Sure.
So,
and that's,
that's the thing about ideologies is
that they tend to tell half the story in
a compelling way and I mean it's also
kind of a nice story if you're a naive
person because you think,
well,
I'm a good person and everybody else I
know is good.
That must come from somewhere.
So it's really interesting you say that.
So we are at Ucla and this is a very
interesting thing and there was a black
woman that said,
candace islands,
I think you're a white supremacist.
Of course,
another black woman.
And I asked her,
I said,
wait a second,
are you a racist?
Are you racist?
No,
I'm not.
Then where's the line?
Where does one stop becoming racist?
Because you're not.
Of course,
right?
You wouldn't be saying this if you
weren't.
So what do I have to do to be more like
you?
It's like everyone else has a horrible
person except me.
Yeah.
You know,
it's that kind of narcissism,
self centerdness.
There's a great quote by Dennis prager
where he said,
growing up in the 19 seventies and
eighties,
we taught our youth that they were the
problem in America was a good thing.
Now it's the exact opposite.
Now it's that America is the problem and
you're the greatest thing ever.
I'm one of the most impactful analysis
you ever made was kind of something Carl
June said is,
you know,
treat others the way,
want to be treated,
but that you don't always want to be
treated with,
you know,
ubiquitous love and kindness.
You want to be sometimes have discipline
thoughts and let lot.
I mean,
one of the things I've learned as a
clinician while in,
as,
as a private person for that matter,
is that we outsource our sanity.
You know,
the psychoanalysts believed,
and most psychologists believe that your
sanity is sort of something you carry
around in your,
in your ego,
in your head.
And if you're saying it's because your,
your psyche as well structured.
But that's actually not true.
It's true to some degree.
But,
but what's more true is that the way you
stay sane is by knowing how to behave in
a manner that makes you sufficiently
acceptable so that other people will put
up with you and then you surround
yourself with other people and hopefully
they're doing reasonably well.
And every time you do something stupid
they slap you on the side of the head,
you know,
either fairly gruffly or subtly by
raising an eyebrow or failing to listen
to you or not,
not phoning you to go out for a beer on
Friday night because then you change
your behavior a little bit.
You reflect,
you say,
we,
I have to do something different while
in you.
If you're lucky,
you have 20 people around you that are
always tapping you and telling you when
you're funny and witty and interesting
and when you're boring and stupid or
more that or less.
Right?
Right,
right.
And so,
so you.
So this,
the social structure plays a key role in
maintaining individuals sanity.
There's no doubt about that.
So I,
I want to switch this a little bit.
I want to get back to some things that
are more specific to you,
so let's talk about your plans for your
organization over the next couple of
years and your goals,
you know,
because a critic might say,
well,
you know,
you're complaining about activism on the
left,
but here you are engaging in activism
and who cares if it's on the right or
the left.
It's still activism and that carries
with it all the problems of activism.
So I'd like you to address that,
but also then to say where you're headed
and how you expect to get there and why.
Sure.
So first I would say we have to reclaim
the term activism.
Activism for the right ideas is virtuous
and correct and always has been,
I think throughout Western civilization
and we're on the side now we're,
we're fighting for intellectual and
ideological diversity and free speech.
Not Activism does not necessarily mean
you have to storm the president's office
or defy the rules that be,
but it does mean you try to be
disruptive on campus wherever necessary.
As long as you're not doing what the
left does,
which is trying to suppress someone
else's rights to speech or try to,
you know,
destroy private property.
So I'll give you a great example.
Me going to UC Berkeley with Dave Rubin
and Candice Owens.
That's a form of activism.
We were welcomed by our group there on
campus.
I'm the young Republican group,
but there was petitions trying to get us
off campus.
There was an immense hostility.
The administration did not want us
there.
We had to pay thousands of dollars for
security fees and for police.
Yeah.
That host security fee thing.
That's pretty.
That's extraordinarily cumbersome.
It well and it essentially so
underhanded.
Absolutely.
It's so unbelievably underhand and so
there's some.
There's an interesting distinction here
that I want to.
I want to make an.
I'd love to get your analysis.
I don't want to deviate too much from
your question,
but for doing this for the years I've
done this,
I'm almost daily.
One of our groups will get disinvited
from campus,
had their funding cut.
Well,
I will get shouted down,
fire alarms polled windows smashed
daily.
Conservatives will try to get disinvited
from campus.
I've never once seen a conservative
student,
a student group,
a conservative group,
or considered professor,
tried to disinvite or try to prevent a
liberal from coming on campus,
not once,
not once.
So you have here the left being the
predominant political viewpoint on
college campuses,
a monopoly,
yet they do everything they can to
prevent anyone else from challenging
that viewpoint and we conservatives are
in the political minority and we
perfectly allow the free discussion and
free flow of ideas.
So to answer your question,
at least from the activism standpoint,
if someone would be a critic of they
say,
well Charlie,
you're just doing the left is doing.
No,
I will defend a socialist right to be
wrong to the death.
I think that free speech and dialog
discussion is,
is the solution.
Well,
I do think to the marketplace of ideas,
civil behavior is unbelievably useful.
You know,
one of the things that I've experienced
over the last couple of years is that if
I keep my head and I stay reasonable in
the face of provocation,
which can be very severe at times,
fire alarms,
being pulled in,
people blowing air horns,
you know,
a foot away from me and getting in my
face in a serious way.
I'm as I'm leaving places that I've been
speaking and carrying a garage which is,
you know,
really pushing it a bit too far as far
as I'm concerned.
And pounding on windows and doors and
creating.
Sure,
yeah,
it's primal.
A good thing to really teach your,
your participants is that there remain
civil and not to engage in acts that
discredit them regardless of the
provocation.
And that's no firearm alarm polling,
that's never yelling people down.
Civil dialogue and proper behave and we
win converts by doing that.
And um,
uh,
and I'll,
I'll send you a couple of videos of,
and I've taken a cue from you.
The way you handled that BBC interview,
which went Shayla for.
Yeah.
So I'm sorry.
Yeah,
the UK.
It was extraordinary.
You had every right to pull her tongue
out.
She was being just,
I mean it was almost impressively
ignorant what she was doing.
Yet you remain so calm and so in control
and I think if you,
even though you had a right to do it,
if you would have went a little bit more
towards the direction of Abrasiveness or
confrontational,
you wouldn't have been as effective.
I learned something,
you know,
and this is something that's worth
knowing is that just because you're
being attacked doesn't mean that's a bad
thing.
You know,
like for now,
let's say that I go and give a talk,
well two things can happen.
I can either give the talk and film that
and put it on youtube and then there's
the advantages of that.
Or I can go give the talk and be shouted
down by protestors.
Like the ones at Queen's university
literally stormed the stage.
I saw that big storm,
this new,
handled it beautifully,
and then you said something like,
this is exactly,
you know,
why we're doing what we're doing,
or something to that effect.
And there's a couple of things.
The first thing is it's not such a
terrible thing for people who are
unreasonable to manifest or
unreasonableness and then to have that
publicized,
that's a good thing.
We do a lot of it and the second thing
is is that just so there's the event
which would be the place that you're
speaking,
but then that's not the event because
all of this is filmed.
The event could easily be in the two
months after it and so one of the ways
that you can keep your head in this sort
of situation is to understand that it
isn't obvious when things are unfolding,
what's good and what isn't and if you
like that interview.
Sure.
I mean,
my sense of the interview was that they
were going to just cut it to five
minutes,
which is what they broadcast and do
everything they could to make me look
like a fool,
you know,
but they put the whole thing up because
they didn't have any idea what happened
in that interview.
No one knew.
It's not like channel four news that
that was a disaster and they put it up
anyways.
They thought the interview went fine and
then were absolutely shocked by the
public response,
but by that time it was too late to
bring it down,
but my point is that it's a lot easier
to keep your head if you don't jump to
conclusions about what's happening in
the moment,
being what's actually happening.
So like it's a long game.
The short case,
so interesting you say that.
So I went to the,
the anti-gun march in Washington DC and
I went and challenged some of these anti
gun protestors and I had someone follow
me around with a camera and I had four
hours of discussions with people.
There was one discussion that I didn't
even remember with a woman.
It was about second amendment rights.
We put it up nine and a half million
views and I couldn't understand what it
was and she was kind of getting very
abrasive,
but she was saying such crazy things,
but I must've struck a chord.
And so interesting you say that,
that there's.
There's two realities and really there's
one where you have.
It's how it's perceived when you're
there,
how people feel and how it sounds,
you know,
Echo,
location wise and all that,
but also the people that watch it when
you cut it up or the video afterwards,
which in some ways is even more
powerful.
Well,
it,
it's,
it is more powerful,
period.
Well,
this is also why I think it's so useful
just to say what you think you know,
in,
in a more fundamental way,
because one of the ideas that has guided
me in doing what I've been doing is that
you wanted,
you want to let go of the consequences
of your actions and say what you believe
to be true.
That doesn't mean you should be a full
about it or that you should say
everything all the time,
but the reason that you.
This is this fundamental hallmark of
faith.
I believe in faith in the truest sense
is the belief that truthful speech
redeemed the world and that's a weird
faith because what that means is that
let's say you say some things and you're
doing your best to be truthful and you
get in trouble.
You Think,
oh my God,
that didn't work.
It's like,
actually you don't know whether or not
it worked because you can't calculate
the full consequences of your action.
And so it could be that it worked just
fine,
but it was painful in the short term and
lots of things that worked fine or
painful in the short term.
And so there is a leap of faith that has
to be made.
And I think that the reason that the
biblical corpus is so powerful in part
is because it's predicated on the
fundamental assumption that truthful
speech turns the potential of of
reality.
The potential is but you free well that
which is,
which is who the hell would ever believe
that,
right?
Because that isn't what,
that isn't how it looks.
What it looks like is that the truth
will get you in trouble.
Of course,
what happens is it gets you in trouble
in the short term and,
and freeze you in the and other people
in the medium to longterm.
And so,
okay,
so back to your plants.
So where are you headed in the future?
So the organization is,
uh,
is growing rather dramatically.
It's quite exciting.
So we have what's called vision 20,
20.
We want to help move youth sentiment
towards free enterprise and free speech,
kind of those general issues,
20 points by 2020.
So we're ramping up our organization
dramatically,
um,
to hopefully a $20,000,000
budget and the higher,
you know,
over 200 people on staff across the
states,
which will be a,
um,
a monumental accomplishment to able to
do is near field staffers.
These are organizers and in some ways my
whole perspective from the very
beginning,
I called ourselves the move on.org
or the right now move on.org
as a political social activism
organization based in the states for far
left wing causes.
I,
I don't.
And to this day with,
this is what drives our organization.
I don't think the left should have a
monopoly on grassroots activism and they
almost always have,
um,
there's no reason for that lot.
The biggest is that we have a builtin
counterrevolution bring on our college
campuses,
uh,
students that are being punished for
thinking differently and there is an
organic uprising of students that are
joining our organization,
attending our events,
you know,
implementing leadership positions in
student government and other places
because they're fed up,
they've had enough and I can't tell what
it would be really good if it for about
15 years it wasn't the most left leaning
radicals who controlled the student
newspapers and the student union.
So it's been like that since I went to
college back in the 19 nineties,
1972.
The programming we're implementing,
it is encouraging our students to run
for student leadership on campus rather
successfully.
Um,
and there's a lot,
there's a lot that we can show to
actually change the campus culture and
climate by doing so that,
that these student unions aren't
divesting from fossil fuels,
fuels are saying there's no such thing
as genders or just astonishingly
radical,
you know,
sentiments.
And so as an organization more broadly,
um,
there,
there's a lot of different ways we
measure success.
Things I can talk about publicly and
things I can't talk about publicly,
but we,
we are,
we are very concerned about the current
trajectory of the west and I believe in,
I said this many times,
I believe the greatest threat to Western
civilization.
What is,
what's happening on American college
campuses?
Um,
it's even more so than any other
geopolitical flow.
It's more so than what's happening in
Washington dc because more than anything
else,
you have a generation that has been
inculcated to believe that America is a
mistake.
Everything about the West is wrong.
Well,
the thing is there,
America is a mistake and so is the west,
but compared to other mistakes,
it's pretty damn.
Like you said,
it's life is suffering.
It's finding the words.
It's finding the best,
worst model that is possible and what so
divine.
I think about what the founding fathers
realized is they said,
yeah,
people suck that systems get corrupted.
Civilizations are ruined.
Things fall apart essentially.
So how do we decentralize that to the
furthest extent so that we can have a
hedge against the inevitability of human
agree with you completely.
I do think that that was the.
That's the fundamental stroke of genius.
It isn't.
How can we bring about utopia is how can
we design a system that idiots can't
screw up too badly given that we're all
idiots?
Precisely.
Yeah.
That's real wisdom and it's,
and it's,
it's,
it's real humility to it is.
It is.
It's real humility as well.
It means that you don't overreach
yourself is that you're not presuming
that you know enough to bring about
heaven on earth,
but that maybe you can stave off the
worst excesses of hell.
That's right,
and what we teach our students and
what's not taught in our schools is the
American founding was the first
political revolution where the victors
voluntarily gave up political power
wash.
It could have been the Washingtonian
Hamiltonian Jeffersonian monarchy that
rule America for the next 200 years.
They would have done quite well,
rich and natural resources,
unaccompanied land that they could have
took over,
but what was so amazing to them and
their motivations,
I believe were pure,
is that they wanted to try something
completely and totally different.
They did not want to embrace that which
they rebelled against,
and as you said,
the humility for them to implement a
system has been replicated all
throughout the west.
I mean the idea of natural rights and
decentralized government in democratic
elections,
in a constitutional republic.
It's what built Western civilization,
Spain,
Portugal,
France,
Denmark,
they all have some form of that
governance,
a little differences here and there.
And,
but now that's being challenged.
That wealth of prosperity and standard
of living increase and human rights
accomplishments is now being in our
university center.
No,
that was.
This is all wrong.
This is all a racist,
homophobic,
bigoted construct designed to benefit
white males.
It's a patriarchy must uproot the
system.
And so more broadly,
um,
we are unbelievably privileged and
blessed to live in Western civilization
even more specifically as an American.
I'm lucky to live in America and I'm
going to fight every single day through
the conduits and the vehicles that I've
created to try to save this experiment
because the,
the,
the move that makes that something other
than Jingoistic,
patriotism is the move that says this is
all good fortune.
And that and,
and that we should be grateful for that
and that our moral obligation is to
sustain that,
to take up the responsibility,
ability necessary to sustain that and to
improve it.
It's not ours by birthright.
Not,
not by any means.
This is also why,
you know,
I'm,
I'm loath to,
this is why I have trouble with right
wing identitarianism because the right
wing identitarian tend to take to
themselves the positive attributes of
their states without having to do the
work necessary to place themselves among
the people who were the actual founders,
without a doubt.
So it's identity politics or the right.
Yeah.
So,
all right,
so where can people learn more about
your organization so that they ignored
our website [inaudible] dot com.
We have a massive conference coming up
that I mentioned that we'd love to,
you know,
of course have you keynote and you're.
And I'll say that I don't know if I said
this,
if I repeat myself,
I apologize.
You know,
I've seen you save people's lives and
you've changed my own and you're the by
far the most requested speaker.
And I guess the question I have for you
in the time,
the short time we have remaining,
I guess is um,
have you,
have you seen any of this visibility or
popularity or fame change you or at
least change your pattern or your style
of life or any of that?
No,
it's completely changed it in some way
somehow.
How do you,
how do you keep order in this?
Because it's chaotic,
isn't it?
I'm not very well,
I from the master of your
infrastructure.
Sure.
You know,
so I have more and more people helping
me all the time and we've been fortunate
because we,
meaning my family because we've gone
through this as a family.
We've been fortunate that people who
have the expertise necessary to help us
with this have showed up at opportune
times.
And I've had enough people around me
with their eyes open to help me point
myself in the right direction and Fal
myself that help.
I would say what it's done to me
personally,
mostly is just to make me more careful
because the costs of mistakes are while
the cost of mistakes for me over the
last two years have been incredibly high
because precise and watching my every
move,
including things that I've done in the
past to see if there's any credible
evidence that I.
Many of the terrible things that people
would like me to be because it's a pain
in the neck for my leftist
opponents,
let's say if I'm not a brute because
then I have to be contended with
seriously.
And so everything I've said and done,
it's been going over with a fine tooth
comb.
And luckily so far that's worked out.
Although,
you know,
that's grace of God and all of that.
And so mostly it's made me more careful
and more awake and more nervous all at
the same time.
You know,
just I wanted to say that you've,
you've kept an unbelievable discipline
of consistency throughout your career
and what I always joke around and we'll
do that to you.
Well,
in proper humility,
which you have.
And um,
few read enough 20th century history and
you actually tried to understand it,
that'll make you humble enough and
because you start thinking that if you
have any sense and you read that
history,
you don't read it as a victim and you
don't read it as the person that would
set things right.
You read it as a perpetrator and you
think,
oh yeah.
So that's what people relate to it.
I'm like,
that's what really,
um,
again,
open my eyes.
One of the stuff you said is imagined
being a prison guard,
Fitz Morris' imagined.
Enjoying it.
That's right.
Imagine benefiting from it,
right?
Which,
which you would.
And you think you're such a good guy.
Really.
You'd stand up to the SS if you were
part of them.
And as you said,
the real evil of Hitler is,
he didn't even use the utility of the
Jews.
He tried to kill Morris.
Has Civilization was crushing around
him.
That's sinister stuff.
I mean,
it would've made more sense to put in
the work camps to make rifles and you
know,
and bombs instead he tried to kill more
of them and all that.
That does seem to indicate that the
fundamental motivation was destruction.
That's regardless of the overlaying
story,
which I think is a perfectly reasonable
hypothesis.
Okay.
So let's say again,
the website.
Sure.
It's a TP USA.com.
So TP USA.com,
they can follow me on twitter.
Uh,
Charlie Kirk Eleven and um,
we're,
we're fighting for the ideas that,
that created once.
It would be nice,
you know,
to,
to think hard about how a couple of
things that might be useful adjuncts and
maybe you guys have thought this through
to your organization is,
you know,
there are places like the Founder
Institute in California that are doing
everything they can to start to help
early stage entrepreneurs and it might
be really nice to make part of your,
um,
your message,
the necessity for the people who are
part of your organization to,
to make a life plan,
to figure out how they're putting
themselves together as individuals to
center the activism on that.
And then to say,
well,
you have to stand up and talk and speak
whenever you're right to do that or your
responsibility to do that as being
interfered with.
But the fundamental thing that you have
to concentrate on is putting your life
in order that,
that keeps the Hubris at bay at least to
some degree that that's correct.
And when you have 1200 women coming
together in June,
that's correct.
Yes.
Phoenix.
Oh,
that's in Dallas.
That's in Dallas.
Of course you have an open invite to
everything and anything.
Well that's curious that,
that'd be something.
Well,
I'm interested in both of those,
you know,
and I would like to.
I haven't spoken to enough to young
women.
I don't think we're doing a young men
summit,
I think next summer to,
of the design around you.
But the young women is interesting.
I'll tell you why.
Um,
I,
it is extraordinarily hard to be a young
conservative on American college campus.
It is a multiple of difficult to be a
young conservative woman.
There's an expectancy of leftism.
There is a hostility towards espousing
any sort of conservative
and the gathering of young ladies
together in this,
in a,
in a summit,
if you will,
which has grown dramatically.
We have 300,
800 and 1200 has been so useful and I'm
a very firm believer in um,
gender segregated education at times and
that's a horrible term,
but you know what I mean?
Essentially having women only events,
um,
there's something quite special that
happens and same with mental events.
That's where the fraternity and sorority
structure came across in North American.
And so we'd love to have you maybe take
a look at that.
Yeah,
well that would be.
I'll do that and we can stay in touch
about that.
And so.
All right,
well thank you.
We should probably bring this to a
close,
so.
Great honor.
Thank you so much for agreeing to know.
Thank you.
This is one of the greatest honors of my
life.
Thank you.
The problem with wanting to be friends
with your child is that that's not good
enough because as a parent,
you're not less than a friend.
You're far more than a friend.
You're someone that's going to be in the
child's life for the duration of your
life with any luck.
You're a longterm island of stability in
a sea of turbulence and the child needs
that far more than than he or she needs
a friend.
Parents need to be courageous because
they have to let their children go and
make mistakes.
You have to let your child fall when
they're learning to walk.
They bump themselves up against the
world a lot and you don't want to do any
more for your child than you absolutely
have to,
and it means that there's a certain
amount of detached harshness that has to
go along with your love and compassion.
You have to stand back and let your
child stumble forward towards mastery.
Today's parents are terrified of their
children because they're often afraid
that if they intervene in their lives,
that they'll make a mistake and that
that will be irrevocable and you have to
have the courage of your convictions.
When you have children and you have to
understand that if you do make mistakes,
that you can learn and you can be
forgiven.
You don't have to be a perfect parent,
although you should aim up with your
children.
Parents are terrified of making
mistakes,
and that means that they're terrified of
being parents and they and that stops
them from being parents.
The.